and you could just see my eyes right
there when he said that ah
hell nah I was talking about this you
was talking about this with who there's
a part of me
um no answers there's a part of me that
is
a bit envious of religious people
I can get that oh yeah you know what yes
and disclaimer neither me or preach or
religious okay well we do come from
households that are semi they're fairly
religious Muslim one and yours being
Christian Baptist my mama gonna it won't
break my mama heart want to hear that
one
my mama's heart been broken oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah but it's okay I just put a check on
the table give her that Devil's lettuce
yeah that green and she'd be like
and the devil's letter is actually weed
so what you just said
he's giving me money to the topic
there's a part of me that does
um Envy religious people yeah but I'll
give you the first floor first what are
the some of the reasons that you
understood what I said I'm curious maybe
because you know when they say ignorance
no I'm not trying to say that I'm Neo
and I'm like you know woke and
everything and stuff and I know the
truth and they don't it's just that I'm
thinking about a lot of things that are
making that don't make sense to me and
they don't have that right and they can
they have this way this this thing that
they can go to and if they feel bad you
know they feel some kind of bad they
could just Jesus
[Laughter]
I came from a mother
that gospel
you know I started liking Kanye getting
some of them church services
[Applause]
[Music]
whenever they sing that's a thing
when you think ugly and you sing with a
purpose okay you don't seem to be you
don't seem to be pregnant he's saying
ugly and you sing with a purpose you
understand what I'm saying that's
something
yes God you sing like your whole life
depends on it you know what D'Angelo
said well he learned to sing in the
church and what his Pastor would say
when he go into the same what do you say
he said you ain't up there to look cute
no you sing it for the Lord you're
saying it you sing it for the Lord so
sing like it you ain't up there to look
cute I said oh and I'm like that's how I
like my you know when you make them face
and you hit the notes and you're like
yeah is it like Greens Greens potatoes
I'm like yeah David I got beans greens
potatoes Tomatoes lamb Rams Hogs dogs
chicken turkeys
that lady
that lady's a pastor she is right she
did her thing yeah and even she was
talking about food you understand there
was a purpose because it was about it
was not just talking about food like the
food that was going to be on the table
that that's given that was not it it was
the food that was going to be on the
table and I was blessed by the Lord
that's what it was you understand what
I'm saying singing with a so when she
sit and she hid that beat your name it
and she hid that note it was with a
purpose so there's always that thing I
understand why people go to church yeah
I understand the feelings I've been
there too and I've like that this old
camaraderie that goes into the church he
got people supporting you and you it's
like it's like kind of a safe space uh
even though there is no such thing as
safe space but it is a safe space for
them to get together and talk about who
whatever they got and even if you talk
about your problems and you're able to
just say oh today I had a bad day
I had a bad day I woke up one morning I
had a bad day people yes my brothers and
sisters I woke up and I felt sad but I
knew that I could have Jesus in my heart
amen and all that just said that opening
up it makes you feel good
you know how you could feel good too
therapy but that's just me okay that's
me that [ __ ] that gospel [ __ ] it is
different and I'm baptized I'm not
Catholic I'm Baptist Baptist so that's
what we did you understand so so I get I
get all that now I envy then because you
know there's always a thing there's
always someone that you can talk to
there's a feeling that there's always
someone that you can tell whether you
can believe it or not you're a Christian
there's someone that you can talk to
there's someone that you can rely on
that you have a purpose in life you
always have to wear people that do not
believe in God
have to work a little bit harder for
that to happen that's true okay and it
is noted that there are more sub
deletions in the people that do not
believe in God than people that believe
because the purpose is not there and you
know what's the world
what what are you going to live for what
was going to be your purpose what's
gonna be your thing well you know when
you don't believe you got to find your
purpose somewhere else when you believe
there's a goal at the end of the title
there's a way there's guidelines I'm not
saying that when you don't believe you
don't got no guidelines but I feel like
you have I've been I've been in both you
have to work a little harder for that to
happen where those guidelines are
bestowed onto you when you believe what
what's your take this video is brought
to you by raycon
yo what's good people the other day I
was really um looking for earbuds uh for
my phone because sometimes I'm doing a
lot of things with my hands and I'm busy
and I want to answer my phone and
everything and stuff and I can't the why
I think doesn't work anymore I was
looking for earbuds I'm going to talk to
you about the raycon earbuds well not
only the envelope and the protector uh
charge the raycons and the earbuds but
that sound quality
the quality yeah oh yeah I said it like
that the quality the bass is nice the
base is Rich it's balanced the quality
is there is sweat and water resistant
because sometimes you know I work out
and when you work out you gotta you want
to Hype yourself up but you don't want
to always have to you know hinder your
earbuds sometimes you want to just
isolate everything out well with the
noise isolation feature on these raycons
you can block out all the noise on you
so you could focus in and Zone in on
what you want to be doing and navigating
between the multiple modes that exist on
raycon has never been easier just use
the function toggle below and it's at a
fraction of the price of what you
usually get you know from other people
you know what I'm talking about click on
the link below right now so if you're
ready to have a completely different
audio experience go to the link in the
description below or go to buy recon.com
Abba to get 15 off on us yeah I think
you touched on it to some degree I think
as you get older you notice that
especially with the current times that
we live now that people sense a
community is pretty much non-existent in
a lot of places and so I think what
church or religion does a lot of the
times is it gives you a sense of
belonging to a group it gives you
communion with it on Sundays or Friday
prayers or you know holidays like Eid
and stuff like that you get this
opportunity to be with others and get
stuff that humans truly need but don't
always accept or admit to and yeah
there's just something super infectious
about being in this kind of environment
you know to hear somebody talk about you
know to have patience because life is
life is full of suffering it doesn't
matter what religion what faith you go
through life is full of suffering being
losing people around you difficult stuff
at work heartbreak all these things and
not having a support system it makes
that suffering even more compounded and
so I have rituals that I engage in all
right I don't mean sacrifice a bit but I
mean like maybe it's specific events I
go to every Thursday or Friday this
dance for you maybe it's CrossFit on
Sundays and you get it with your group
of people having these forms of like rep
repetition where you guys go through the
same habits with the same type of people
like that especially during after this
pandemic can no longer be discounted how
much people are suffering from not being
able to do those things
unbelievable for me was like such a big
deal why I look a lot better now and
feel a lot better is because I'm out
there and I'm actually able to do [ __ ]
because I wasn't able to for a long time
so
I say all this to say that religious
people just from a community standpoint
have so much but then like preach said
it gives you a set of guidelines it
gives you your moral compass it tells
you like these are the rights these are
the wrongs instead of you having to
figure out a lot of it for yourself all
the time or have something to deal with
that and I think a lot of people need
you know
they need that framework you know what
I'm saying and so from the outside
looking in when I see folks who are so
lost and have none of that you can go
through and try to figure out yourself
but that's a one it can be very lonely
and two very difficult oh yeah very
difficult and so I think there's a part
of me that understands the need for
religion even though I'm not a Believer
or not I don't think that can change I
respect it and I appreciate it from afar
and I think yeah that's something that's
come with AIDS before I just I used to
think of it as a nuisance because it was
something that people kept trying to
impose on me but now that they no longer
have that ability and I'm a grown man I
can look at it from afar and appreciate
it for what it is rather than the thing
that's trying to pull me in all the time
well you know this this I was pissed off
about religion you you were
uh bring it up a couple notches and live
it okay yeah live it about about our
religion and stuff like that and you
know through the years you know you
can't you calm down you listen you know
you know you just have to work things
out with what hurts you and what hurt
your community and what hurt your people
and understand where it comes from I was
pissed off yeah like
you would talk about you would talk
about religion to me
Christianity to me and my whole demeanor
would change like I was in a fight mode
you saw that a couple of times
I was I was heated you understand and I
was I was King preached the petty
King preached the petty in full effect I
was ready to take you down and all your
arguments it was easy to invalidate them
real quick now it's not even about that
it's not even about that but I was piss
pissed yeah especially when someone's
trying to Embark me in that [ __ ] that's
cause you ain't got Jesus in your life
oh I got one for you you got a problem
let God handle it oh my God that used to
trigger the F and not up to recently oh
yeah we got a video I thought the most
viral video yes is him getting triggered
by God yes when when the wedding thing
and when God what he said let go I need
a prenup no no no let God handle it I I
you could just go you could go back to
that video actually the preacher stepson
he's like hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on he say now now hold on don't
now I know you love this girl
don't make a drastic decision I think
you should just let God handle it shut
that [ __ ] off
and you could just see my eyes right
there when he said that oh
hell nah yeah that was up to recently
and as he was doing that all I was
thinking
here we go sure enough highest viewed
video shoot that video went up and beat
the first one that we posted yeah yeah
imagine that but yeah but like yeah that
[ __ ] used to trigger you yeah
it's understandable like it doesn't
trigger me but I I got a little yeah no
no but now I could breathe yes knock a
breathe but before I was going every
time I was going I feel you I get you
I'll say this
I think now we're at a point where
people have so many options they can
choose to do whatever they want to do
when people are embellishing a lot of
those things they're [ __ ] left right
and Center they're doing all kinds of
substances they're doing all these
things and we allow people a lot of
freedoms but what comes with a lot of
freedoms oftentimes especially if people
embellish too much is chaos comes into
your life all of a sudden you have a
harder time meeting deadlines you're
engaging all kinds of frivolous Behavior
that's not good for you and I think what
religion brings for a lot of people is a
bit of order every Sunday
ritualistically You're supposed to show
up here or if you have an issue you can
come to somebody and confide it gives
you that sense of consistency that I
think a lot of people need in their
lives to feel really well I have friends
who are dealing with antidepressants and
stuff like that and I'm not saying they
find God they felt better what I'm
trying to say is just from them getting
a schedule and an order in their life
getting a job and working nine to five
every single day they started to feel
exponentially better and that's actually
one of the top things that like shrinks
will tell people when they're dealing
with depression sometimes is like get a
schedule just pick three things in the
day and get those things done and see
how we feel after that and just bring
some order what I think religion does a
great job of is it oftentimes introduces
order into your life it gives you these
guidelines where it says don't do too
much of this don't too much of B don't
do too much to see blah blah blah blah
blah or come every Sunday do these
things and that kind of order is very
comforting
um and I also think as people get older
they need that because they retire from
their jobs they have all this free time
their kids don't come to see them as
often they're community members friends
family move away or they die as you get
older that need for that kind of ordered
consistency and something to invest your
time in becomes much more apparent you
know because someone said this to me
it's like his mom turned 70 and she's
thinking about retirement and then you
know she doesn't know what she can do at
retirement so he's like oh you should
pick up a new hobby or whatever she's
like I'm 70.
like that's probably not and most old
people not going to go and like pick up
a Guitar all of a sudden or you know
start a botany plan or whatever most of
them got their routinely like that kind
of stuff so she started investing
herself heavily to God you don't even
know her husband passed away and you see
like there's a beauty in that there's a
community that's going to take care of
you exactly and that when you're
familiar with and you've invested in for
40 50 years right you're gonna have
people calling you up
how are you doing today absolutely
there's people calling you when you
ain't got nobody you know people are
gonna call you people are going to take
care of you people want to look out for
you that's how that's what you need yeah
sometimes that's what you need yeah
think about this and this really [ __ ]
me up when he said it he said
my mom been going to church
since she was her old baby she's 71.
every Sunday think of one thing that
you've done every Sunday that's a social
activity
I want you the viewer tell me one thing
that you've done every single week since
you were a baby that's socially involved
with other people and communicating
not oh I work out every Sunday not that
I'll talk about something that you've
done real religiously
right think about there's something
really like impressive and beautiful in
that in and of itself
um and so yeah it's like that yeah I got
one like like that yeah no matter where
she at she going she's in Florida she's
in New York because y'all should go to
church good that was a church good that
that kind of order and if she doesn't go
to church you must believe that within
between that time and that time you
cannot go in a room because she praying
yeah she praying she doing prayers she
prays for everybody
and I even used to that's how pissed off
I was and when people would come up to
you would come up to me and be like oh I
prayed for you I'd be like nah I don't
believe in that [ __ ] so don't
now I'm not as Petty and I understand
that the only thing that person is doing
whenever they they say I've been praying
for you is they wish you well
it's accepted it's not your religion
it's not your thing okay the the
intention behind that is that that
person is wishing me well I I'm proud of
your growth
thanks
but if
you get upset you deal with
Massachusetts let God handle it it's
okay [ __ ] don't push it don't push it
don't [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
a religious video is coming oh yeah yeah
actually yeah there's a lot of people
that will be asking like yo why why were
you so pissed off we'll we'll handle
that in another video nothing I think
that could be a part too we can drop
this video we could definitely do that
why you left if you want to talk about
it me I mean mine's boring
I like [ __ ]
and I'm not good at being a hypocrite
oh
it wasn't alcohol was it I like [ __ ]
[ __ ] I knew I was gonna [ __ ] left or
right if we have to go to Friday prayers
and be like God and I knew that night I
was going I couldn't do that Mia I can't
one thing I can't do is be a blade
neighbor I just can't you try you're
trying to pray I try you try to pray but
all the time you're praying you're
looking at the watch to see whenever
you're going when I see Imam and then I
also seen them at the club see me like I
I I can't be me I'm just sorry I just
can't beat me that's all so I knew who I
was and I knew what I was about now my
old years maybe maybe you never know but
I I don't see myself but why I left I
like yeah I mean it is what is it so
that's all anything else you want to say
that's both of us all right that's what
you got